Jessie Gironde a d'abord été professeur
de copie dans un atelier en région
parisienne avant de devenir
restauratrice d'art mais l'envie de
transmettre sa passion la conduite à
créer son atelier à Tours j'ai pu
aborder 4 techniques qui sont
les portraits du Fayoum c'est le premier
siècle au 4e après Jésus-Christ
c'est une technique à la cire
épigments ensuite il y a la température
à l'oeuf autre technique la peinture à
l'huile classique et une technique mixte
propre à Rembrandt le célèbre peintre
hollandais du XVIIe siècle en ce moment
c'est une copie de son autoportrait que
Jessie réalise à petite touche
dans l'éclair dans les blancs il
utilisait une émulsion à base de de
jaune d'oeuf d'huile de lin et de blanc
titane et pour le reste on utilisait de
l'huile une peinture à l'huile plus
classique
ces recettes sont fabriquées sur place
et se transmettent d'ateliers en atelier
car il y a peu d'écrits et pour être
copiste il faut être très patient
observateur et savoir oublier sa
créativité c'est vraiment un oubli de
soi parce qu'on doit se plonger dans ce
que le peintre le maître ancien moderne
a ressenti a fait il faut vraiment se
plonger dans son travail alors avec
beaucoup d'humilité attention
on ne fait jamais une copie parfaite on
n'est pas le peintre de toute manière
mais par contre on cherche à comprendre
son oeuvre et à
s'en rapprocher au maximum si les cours
de copistes vous tentent il faudra
patienter jusqu'en septembre mais Jessy
l'assure pas besoin de savoir dessiner
pour peindre à la manière des grands
maîtres